The demon inside the hero. It’s a an anime
trope as old as time. Naruto and the nine
tails. Asta in Black clover. Ichigo in Bleach.
Inuyasha. Chainsawman. The list goes on and on
and if you’ve watched any anime, like ever,
you will know that the main character always
has to face his inner demon, overcome it and then
grow stronger. You know, it’s a metaphor. So it’s
actually quite refreshing, that Jujutsu Kaisen
took this anime trope, like so many others,
and flipped it completely on its head, as Itadori
Yuji is just crushed over and over again by the
far stronger and far smarter Sukuna. But…what
if Yuji was more like the rest of the Shonen
Protagonist and could actually learn to control
Sukuna and make use of his insane powers?
This one change would make the entire story
of Jujutsu Kaisen completely different. When
normal - but super strong - high school student
Yuji Itadori finds himself face to face with a
monstrous curse terrorizing his friends, he makes
a split-second decision that changes his life. He
eats a Special Grade Cursed Object: AKA one of the
twenty fingers of Sukuna. And as Gojo reminds us,
this isn’t counting toes - Sukuna has four
arms because he’s just built different.
Normally, this would kill him instantly, but
Yuji is a super special shonen protagonist,
so instead he emerges as a
suitable vessel for Sukuna.
The thing is, Yuji isn’t able to access
any of Sukuna’s insane powers - he can
just take back control of his body
and suppress Sukuna inside of him.
But what would it be like if instead of just
being able to take back control of his body,
Yuji could actually just
access Sukuna’s insane power?
First off, Satoru Gojo would be a LOT more
suspicious of the whole situation. In the
normal story, he fought with Sukuna for
ten seconds as a test to see if Yuji could
take back control at will. But if normal Yuji was
ALSO as strong as Sukuna without him taking over,
he’d probably be more likely to think
Sukuna was just acting with his best
Yuji impression to trick them into thinking he
was suppressed. Yuji would let the slashes fly
giving Gojo about a million cuts that he’d
have to heal with Reverse Cursed Technique.
Gojo would probably ask Yuji a series of questions
that only the real Yuji would know. He’d ask
stuff like “what’s your birth date?”, “What’s
your mother’s maiden name?” (it’s Kenjaku),
“What’s the name of the street you grew up on?”
Then, of course, Megumi would yell at his sensei
because neither of them would have any idea at
all what the answers to those questions were.
The higher-ups, especially, would want Yuji dead,
just like they did in the normal story. After all,
the only thing more dangerous than a resurrected
ancient curse user is a teenager with unlimited
power. However, after Gojo was fully
satisfied that it was Yuji in control,
he would still vouch for him and convince the
higher-ups. After all, he was Gojo, and he
could simply stop Yuji if he went rogue since he
only had one finger’s worth of power at the time.
Of course, shortly after Yuji’s power level
would grow to two fingers as Gojo would give
him another one that Jujutsu High had on hand as
a means of testing his ability as a vessel. With
each finger that Sukuna regains, his total
power grows. However, this doesn’t actually
affect Yuji’s base power. He still needs to
work on developing his own strength because
he’s unable to access Sukuna’s well of power.
In this scenario, though, all of that finger
power may as well be Yuji’s because he can use it
all without having to give up control to Sukuna.
Now let’s flash forward to Yuji’s next big moment.
For a lot of fans, the point where they realized
that Jujutsu Kaisen was not their standard series
was when the main character nearly literally died
in just the sixth episode. But in this timeline,
with Yuji getting access to Sukuna’s power without
him totally losing control, things would go down
very differently when the Special Grade Cursed
Spirit showed up, spawning from the Cursed
Womb. This Cursed Womb became a Special Grade
spirit called a Finger Bearer specifically
because it consumed one of Sukuna’s fingers.
Instead of Yuji, Megumi, and Nobara’s
only options being to run or die,
this time Itadori would have the power to fight.
Now in the real show, Sukuna made short work of
this powerful cursed spirit - but in exchange
Yuji lost control of his body and Sukuna was
able to take him hostage: AKA ripping out
his heart and threatening to kill him, only
offering to use his reversed curse technique to
heal him if he’ll make a Binding Vow - This vow,
unbeknownst to Yuji since he literally forgot
about it due to the conditions of the bargain,
would have terrible, terrible,
TERRIBLE consequences down the line.
However, if Yuji could use Sukuna’s strength
without the downsides, he’d eliminate the
cursed spirit no problem. Sukuna showed
this Cursed Womb his domain expansion,
but since Yuji wouldn’t even know what
this was yet, he’d just put the Cursed
Spirit through the Slap-Chop and cut it into a
million cursed pieces. Then the gang would all
be free to grab a bowl of ramen afterward.
Of course, that’s not the only thing Yuji
gets to chow down on - he’d also be free to
chomp on yet another Sukuna finger that was
housed inside the Cursed Womb. This would bring
Yuji to a power level of exactly three fingers.
It’s around this time that Jogo
would try to kill Gojo, however,
this time Yuji wouldn’t be in secret training
since he didn’t fake die. I’m going to say that
Gojo would still have him do his Netflix Binge
Watch training program to try and get a hang
on cursed energy. As Yuji’s finger number
increases more and more, the risk of Sukuna
gaining control would be higher and higher, so
having him complete his cursed energy training
would be especially important. After all, even
if Sukuna didn’t take control, somebody without
experience trying to use his power might
cause untold destruction just by accident.
Anyway, Mr. Volcano Head would want to have
a word with Gojo, foolishly thinking that he
was even remotely a match. By the way, I
really wish his name was just Mr. Volcano
Head - that way I wouldn’t keep getting Jogo
and Gojo mixed up in my script. Thanks, Gege.
Just like in the main series, Gojo would
use this opportunity to teach Yuji about
the wonderful world of Domain
Expansion. This time, though,
after seeing Gojo’s Unlimited Void
in action, Yuji would say “ooh, ooh,
ooh - let me try!” and whip out a Malevolent
Shrine. Or as Crunchyroll likes to call it,
a Malevolent Kitchen. However, Jogo isn’t getting
cooked just yet…we’ll save that for Shibuya.
Outclassed by not one, but two Jujutsu Sorcerers,
Jogo would once again flee the scene with the help
of his most flowery friend and decide that maybe
he needs Kenjaku’s help with Gojo after all.
Onto Junpei! In the real timeline of Jujutsu
Kaisen, Yuji befriends a high school student
called Junpei. Unfortunately, Junpei had
made another friend recently: Mahito,
the human curse - er, to be clear, that’s not
like a human/curse combo like Sukuna. No, Mahito
is a curse born from humanity’s fear of itself,
making him one of the scariest curses of all.
Due to Junpei’s parents being divorced
and his constant bullying at school,
he’s adopted an extremely negative view of
humanity. Mahito takes advantage of this,
but Yuji genuinely tries
to become Junpei’s friend.
However, this short arc culminates in
a huge battle at Junpei’s high school,
when Mahito uses his Idle Transfiguration
to turn Junpei into a monster who he can
use against Yuji. According to Mahito,
there is no way to bring Junpei back.
Yuji begs Sukuna for help. He knows Sukuna
can masterfully heal wounds - after all,
he’d replaced Yuji’s entire heart with
Reverse Cursed Technique. However,
in the real series Sukuna and Mahito
just laugh and mock Yuji in one of the
most memorable panels from the whole series. Gege
Akutami sure knows how to draw a demented smile.
However, if Yuji could control Sukuna’s
powers, that would include his Reverse
Cursed Technique. Using this power, he
could reverse Mahito’s ability. Mahito
states that it’s impossible to do, but
for all we know, Mahito just says this
to harm Yuji more. Maybe with the power of
someone like Sukuna, it’s possible after all.
Gege would have to take a cue from Eiichiro
Oda because Mahito would make a Shocked Enel
face as Junpei was de-platypused. He’d
be so in shock, he’d barely see it coming
when Yuji pulled out the death by a thousand
cuts. Mahito can change the shape of souls,
but his soul would be in about a billion
pieces after Yuji was done with him.
Yuji would be able to fight against him
with the full strength of Sukuna. AKA,
Mahito’s getting cooked in the
Malevolent Kitchen. After all,
Yuji is no match for Mahito at this point in the
story, but Sukuna’s power outclasses him by miles.
And Mahito being super dead is going to
really come into play later - you know,
because of Shibuya. But for now,
Junpei and Yuji would celebrate,
Junpei realizing the errors of his ways
after Mahito took advantage of him and
the two teens would go catch a movie
where absolutely no heads exploded.
Up next, we get a Family Reunion where Itadori
gets to meet his siblings. Enter the Cursed Womb:
Death Paintings. These guys are like the Cursed
Womb from earlier only wayyyyy worse. They were
created by Kenjaku, the ultimate villain of JJK,
who was inhabiting the body of Noritoshi Kamo,
who gained the title of the most Evil Sorcerer
in HIstory. To create the Death Paintings,
he mixed the blood of cursed spirits and humans to
create creatures who were a hybrid of both. Aaaand
since Kenjaku is also Yuji’s mom (long story),
this makes Eso, Kechizu, and Choso technically
his brothers. Step brothers? Half brothers?
Curse brothers? Once again the team of Megumi,
Kugisaki, and Yuji will destroy these guys and
Yuji will slurp up yet another delectable digit.
And now it’s the moment you’ve all
been waiting for! Happy Halloween
because in Jujutsu Kaisen time it’s October
31st…the night of the Shibuya Incident.
This is where the differences really
start coming along because Yuji has
already destroyed Kenjaku’s plans.
Mahito was essential for helping
keep Gojo busy and distracted so they could
trick him into getting caught by the Prison
Realm. Mahito also kills fan favorites
Nanami and maybe Nobara. Come on, Gege,
would it kill you to just let us know what
happened to our favorite hammer girl already??
In this scenario, the Disaster Curses are
especially motivated to get rid of Gojo
AND Yuji. They need Gojo clear so they can
fulfill their goal of taking out humanity and
letting curses rule the world. The group
would still successfully capture Gojo,
but less thanks to the Disaster Curses and more
thanks to the Human Disaster: Kenjaku, or Pseudo
Geto as Gojo sees him. The World’s Strongest
Sorcerer would be caught in the Prison Realm,
leaving the rest of the fighters to deal with
three Special Grade Curses and their allies.
Choso would still fight Yuji and slow him down
from being able to set Gojo free before the
Prison Realm was sealed, allowing Gojo to still be
captured. Choso would use his blood manipulation
to fire off rounds at Yuji, but he’d dodge them
with ease. Just before Yuji uses his Sukuna powers
to absolutely chop up Choso, they’ll realize that
they are brothers. Yuji will be confused, but glad
to accept another ally on their side as the two
go to face down the remaining Disaster Curses.
During this arc, Mimiko and Nanako would
still feed Yuji a finger. These two girls
were followers of Suguru Geto prior to his
death, and therefore wanted to offer a finger
as an offering to Sukuna so that they could ask
him to kill Kenjaku for them since he had taken
over their old master’s body. In the actual story
Sukuna kills them, perceiving them giving him
an order as an unforgivable offense. However,
Yuji will be more than happy to use the finger
boost to go after Kenjaku, especially since
Kenjaku just imprisoned his own master. The
ever-polite Yuji would bow deeply after the gift
of another finger and go off to kill Kenjaku.
However, Jogo would absolutely not give Yuji the
ten fingers he’d been hoarding. Since the King
of Curses was essentially being held hostage
by Yuji Itadori in this alternate timeline,
he’d want those fingers as far away
from Yuji as he could get them.
Instead, in our timeline, it would come down to
an all out battle between the Disaster Curses,
Kenjaku, and Yuji’s Five Finger
Death Punch. However, Yuji would
have the backing of the other Jujutsu
Sorcerers. Of course, Hanami the nature
curse was already exorcised by Gojo before
he was trapped in the prison realm. Dagon,
the water-based curse would still be a problem,
but just like he does in the normal series the
recently resurrected Toji Fushiguro would
be there to help beat the curse to a pulp.
Jogo would be the biggest problem of the three.
Fifteen Finger Sukuna made short work of him,
but this time Yuji would only have five fingers
worth of strength. Therefore, he wouldn’t be
able to absolutely flex on Mr. Volcano Head
with his own fire-based attack. Instead,
Yuji would use his normal strategy of dicing
and slicing to turn Jogo into minced meat.
All that’s left is Kenjaku, but after seeing
everything that had just gone down…well,
let’s just say Kenjaku is smart enough to read
the room and know when to dip. Getting up close
and personal with the combat isn’t Kenjaku’s
usual style. The dude can absolutely fight,
but he’s not trying to take on all of Jujutsu
High plus a Sukuna Strengthened Yuji. After all,
he’s cunning and manipulative - he likes to
make plans and have others enact them for him.
Since he’d lost Mahito, his biggest strategy
for enacting the Culling Game by stealing
his ability was already gone, too. Therefore,
having succeeded in his goal of Sealing Gojo,
he’d retreat to gather new allies
and fight another day. Sadly,
this means he wouldn’t get to reunite
with his beloved son Yuji just yet,
but it would only be a matter of time before
he would get things to go his way once again.
Of course, if Yuji did have control of
Sukuna’s power, the show wouldn’t be nearly
as interesting unless they gave Yuji an enemy
who was truly on his level. If Sukuna’s power
was on the side of good, what character could
possibly rival him? Gojo Satoru. Thankfully,
he’s on our side, but if his backstory
had gone just a little bit differently,
could his insane power have gotten to his head
and made him go against the Jujutsu Society?
What would it take for Gojo to turn evil? You can
see my answer to that question in this next video.